>> Stephen: WELCOME BACK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NATION, YOU KNOW, YOU READ THE
PAPERS, YOU KNOW THAT WE
AMERICANS LIVE IN AN
UNPRECEDENTED ERA OF
COMMUNICATION TECHNOLOGY, FROM
TABLETS TO SMARTPHONES TO
FUTURISTIC GLASSES THAT
INSTANTLY SEND THE MESSAGE,
I'M A DOUCHE.
NOW THERE'S A NEW APP THAT HAS
EXPANDED THE POSSIBILITIES FOR
COMMUNICATION BY DRASTICALLY
REDUCING THEM.
>> THERE'S A NEW SMARTPHONE APP
SIMPLY CALLED YO. USERS CONNECT
WITH EACH OTHER THROUGH THE FREE
APP AND PUSH ONE BUTTON TO
SEND THE WORD YO TO A CONTACT.
SO FAR, 50,000 USERS HAVE SENT
ABOUT FOUR MILLION YO'S.
>> Stephen: THAT'S RIGHT, YO,
AN APP ALREADY HUGELY POPULAR
WITH THE WORLD'S POPULATION OF
SYLVESTER STALLONE.
NOW, WHEN I FIRST LEARNED ABOUT
AN APP THAT BOILS DOWN ALL YOUR
COMMUNICATION INTO TWO LETTERS,
I EXPRESSED MYSELF IN ONE.
Y?
( APPLAUSE )
BUT I JOINED--
( CHEERS )
I JOINED THE YO-TH MOVEMENT WHEN
I READ THE COMPANY BOASTS IT
TAKES 11 TAPS TO SEND THE WORD
YO ON A RIVAL MESSAGING SERVICE
COMPARED TO TWO ON THEIR APP.
THAT'S A NINE-TAP DIFFERENCE
DIFFERENCE.
TAPS YOU COULD BE SPENDING WITH
YOUR CHILDREN.
( LAUGHTER )
BUT THE TRUE BEAUTY OF ONLY
SAYING YO IS IT SAYS SO MUCH.
AS ITS DEVELOPER PUTS IT WE LIKE
TO CALL IT CONTEXT-BASED
MESSAGING.
YOU UNDERSTAND BY THE CONTEXT
WHAT IS BEING SAID.
CONTEXT IS EVERYTHING.
IN THE OLD DAYS IF I TEXTED
SOMEONE THE WORD YO, AND I
WANTED THEM TO KNOW WHAT IT
MEANT, I HAD TO FOLLOW UP WITH
GURT.
AND YO IS ALSO GOOD FOR
BUSINESS.
FOR INSTANCE, AN ICE CREAM TRUCK
CAN YO THE KIDS WHEN ITS
AROUND THE CORNER.
IMAGINE GETTING A YO FROM THE
ICE CREAM TRUCK, AND PARENTS CAN
SIGN UP TO TELL THEIR KIDS TO
STAY AWAY FROM ANYONE WITH THE
USER NAME "THEICECREAMTRUCK."
BUT WHY ARE THEY LIMITING THIS
BREAKTHROUGH TO JUST OUR PHONES?
I BELIEVE WE CAN IMPLEMENT YO'S
CONTEXT-BASED COMMUNICATION
PHILOSOPHY IN EVERYDAY LIFE.
COME ON OUT, JAY.
JAY THE INTERN, EVERYBODY.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
YO.
>> YO.
>> Stephen: YO.
>> Stephen: YO-YO-YO-YO.
>> YO.
>> Stephen: YO! YO.
YO.
>> Stephen: YO!
>> YO.
( LAUGHTER )
>> Stephen: YO.
♪ YO, YO, YO ♪
( CHEERS )
>> Stephen: YO-YO-YO-YO.